we're told that casey buys a bracelet
she pays for the bracelet and pays 72
cents in sales tax the sales tax rate is
what is the original price of the blade
bracelet before tax
so pause this video and see if you can
figure this out
well let's think about how your sales
tax is calculated your sales tax
sales tax
would be equal to the sales tax rate
i'll just call that the rate
so that's going to be equal to the rate
times your original price original
original price
and what do we know here well they tell
us what our sales tax is our sales tax
is 72 cents so i'll write that here so
72 cents is going to be equal to my
sales tax rate they also tell us that
that is six percent
is going to be equal to six percent
times my original price and that's what
they're asking for the original price so
times i'll just call it let's just call
it p for short original price and so you
have it we have a fairly straightforward
equation now and now i'm just going to
rewrite everything as a decimal so we
could write we could write
0.72 is equal to
6 percent is the same thing as 6 per 100
which is the same thing as 600
0.0
six hundredths
times p
and now we can just divide both sides by
six hundredths to solve for the original
price
so let's do that
all right
so on the right hand side i have a p
on the left hand side if i have 72
hundredths divided by 6 hundredths well
that's going to be equal to 12. 12 times
6 is 72. six hundredths times 12 would
be 72 hundredths and so this is going to
be equal to
is going to be equal to 12. so the
original price of the bracelet before
tax is 12 dollars and you can verify
that 6 percent of 12.
0.0.2
times 12 is indeed 72 hundredths let's
do another example
a store has a 25 percent off sale on
coats
with this discount the price of one coat
is 34.50
what is the original price of the coat
so once again pause this video and see
if you can figure it out and this these
examples they're actually quite useful
because you will encounter this all of
the time
when you are shopping or you're trying
to calculate tax or you're buying
something so think about this can you
figure out the original price of the
code
all right well let's just write out
write it out the same way we did last
time so let's say our original price
original
price
and then there's a 25
discount so minus 25
of the original price original
original price
is going to be equal to 34.50 is equal
to
34.50 because that's the price with the
discount so can we solve for the
original price
so one way to think about it this is 100
of the original price or one times the
original price minus 25 of the original
price is going to be equal to this
well 1 100 minus 25 of something is
going to be 75 percent
of our original price
original
this is why people use letters for
variables so they don't have to keep
writing this over and over again is
going to be equal to
50. and now to solve for our original
price we just divide both sides by 75
percent and 75 percent that's the same
thing as 75 per 100 or 75 hundredths
so
i could divide both sides by 75
hundredths 75 hundredths
on the left-hand side these two are
equivalent so i'll be left with my
original price and now i just have to
figure out what is this going to be so
if i take 75 hundredths and let me
actually multiply both of these times
100. so this is going to be the same
thing as
3450 divided by 75. i just did that to
get rid of the decimals i moved
essentially the decimal both decimals to
the right two places multiplying the
numerator and the denominator by a
hundred
so let's see how many times 75 goes into
3450.
see 75 doesn't go into 3 doesn't go into
34. it does go into
345. what is that 4 times
times 5 is
20.
4 times 7 is 28 plus 2
300 and then you subtract you have 45
bring down the zero 450
75 goes into 450
times 6 times 5 is 30.
6 times 7 is 42 plus 3 is indeed 45 and
we luckily have no remainder so this
right over here is going to be equal to
46 dollars our original price is 46 you
take off one fourth or 25 percent you're
left with 34.50 and that makes intuitive
sense as well always good to just take
whatever answer you have and put it back
in and see if if if it makes sense in
terms of you know somehow you got 460
dollars
instead taking 25 percent off you get to
34.50 you said well that sounds off or
if you've got four dollars he said you
take 25 off and you got 34.50 that would
have also felt off but 46 feels right
and you can even calculate that what is
twenty five percent of forty six dollars
subtract that from forty six and you
should get thirty four dollars and fifty
cents